welcome to this video playing Gaillard
not sure to pronounce that okay i played
this Bishop g5 move against the Dutch a
number of times times recently with
quite quite good results then try very
interesting h6 center here is he really
going to play g5 don't believe it what a
what a bottom move lucky for can you
play like that like this kind of in
gambit style or maybe start with this
and then maybe g5 okay let's let's just
let's just try this Knight takes Queen
age 5 is mate this is easy but not very
likely to happen admittedly some trying
for this approach may be Bishop f5 yeah
it's not clear that this is compensation
right yeah well at least I've got the
bishop there so that he cannot easily
castle and displayed c6 which is quite
good news in terms of long castles now
go here 93 are not clear this is a bit
annoying ok maybe win a tempo here i was
thinking originally of castling long but
maybe this is not a good idea at all
should just just castle short yeah why
not
yeah maybe that's not so bad it should
be a bit of compensation for the pond
not sure how much but there is some
compensation at least if I has attacked
quite a number of times and he can take
on see three years to to keep it the e4
pawn should I take how should i take
this interesting question I'll take this
not so much for the pawn structure but
for the idea to play the Queen to g3
this is quite nice I can think about
this with Bishop to g6 where is he going
and then taking here I can't a I can do
that can take on no one f5 actually
quite nice
not sure we have six was check really
advisable and now look f1 just pinning
it all then on then that's not if six is
not really so great probably it's better
to just take it right check and now
let's consider if I give this check yes
so I also have the screen we three Queen
B seven check it's probably better it's
probably better you must go to 12 g6 now
and now that's interesting what now hmm
this is some way to continue the tech or
should I just take here or taking us is
really good young the Queen cannot be
attacked here and I can just put it on
e5 the bishop and just a very good
position yeah it's just it support and a
very strong position maybe there was
something even more decisive but it's
it's very much very much sure enough I
think um say rookie 494 Queen g7 it's no
major rookie three maybe rookie 3g three
looks quite dangerous I can take on my
first this one check and then i take i
can take on g7 and d7 okay check black
resides yeah this fellow for this fell
apart pretty quickly probably I thought
that here he probably should go look up
sembuh thought rook f7 to take the tour
take like that just a much better
version of all this check the same
position like in the game but with an f
porn which is of course a big difference
check it this still looks quite good for
white but it's not like I'm winning it
still feels a bit shaky in blacks
position but it wouldn't wouldn't do win
i think this just flat-out wins for
white hey I does check check and rookie
falls even strong bias now I had I had
the suspicion ready but ok um this
potatoes was probably good enough right
yeah plus force quite enough yeah but I
don't think all this opening I have my
doubts about it but it turned out to be
quite quite interesting and I think
actually after this he should probably
not place his six this move is not
helping him so much if you look at this
structure what exactly is c6 doing here
I'm not threatening anything and I way
that's even a technical problem with it
and I just recognized it I can take here
which is very very good for white of
course this is entirely check oops come
on
entirely unplayable giving wider monster
position without even having material
sacrificed so then see success is really
bad he should probably just try to
protect this pawn like that and keep the
option of knight c6 Queen d7 non castles
open which probably leads to a very good
position for black this is similar to it
to a somewhat miss plate stone gambit so
prolly for it's not a good news of
course I can play out any normal move
here but i wanted to this is somehow
somehow looked interesting but it
doesn't seem to be objectively good in
the game i mean even after this i really
have some compensation that so maybe not
enough for a computer to to like but it
is quite playable this position i have a
good development and and activity
against those so weak pawns alright
thanks for watching